drawing back the curtains on what some
women experience every day
titled masculine poetry this art project
aims to explain the men what it is like
for women to be subjected to sexual
harassment
this husband and wife and two of the
artists behind the exhibition say it's
inspired by experiences their daughter
had growing up in the south of france
we made this project for men and we
realized that it had an enormous impact
on women too for men there's a
realization for women they feel they're
allowed to talk i think what would be
interesting would be to have teenagers
go through it as well because at that
age they learned this behavior it would
enable them to understand and afterwards
we need debates between men and women so
that the world changes so that there is
a change of behavior
[Music]
visitors are led through a darkened
tunnel lined with sounds and images of
leering men
it was hell but also there are no
surprises it feels like what we're used
to and i think it's interesting to put
that in an exhibition i think it's
interesting to see what men think about
it too
set to open next month the project will
have psychological experts on hand to
accompany viewers
but before its launch there's been
interest from politicians and human
rights campaigners who have come to this
preview in a hangar in brussels
local authorities across belgium have
expressed their interest in a version of
the show going on tour
priscilla is a police officer who works
with victims of domestic abuse and she
says it will help
my first reaction is that there are very
few victims who dare to file a complaint
as a policewoman i am putting myself in
the role of my colleagues out on patrol
in police vehicles or on the street i
don't think for us it's possible to
witness this sort of thing as obviously
to catch people in the act have evidence
of this sort of phenomenon so i think
there is a lot of work to be done and it
begins with building awareness
those behind this project say they hope
it will encourage a greater awareness of
how harassment affects women
and that those who suffer it could be
anyone's partner mother
daughter sister or friend
julian wolfe al-jazeera